nasa has been gearing up to return
astronauts to the moon for the first
time in more than half a century they've
got the flag up now and you can see the
stars
as soon as the end of august the space
agency plans to conduct the first launch
of the massive rocket system for its
moon exploration program artemis the
first mission artemis one will send a
spacecraft on an uncrewed trip around
the moon so artemis one is is a test run
it's a test run for the rocket system
for the the spacecraft for the ground
systems the ground infrastructure it
will be a critical step towards landing
people on the moon by 2025 but over the
last few years nasa and its partners
have experienced a range of technical
legal and cost related delays there's a
lot of elements that you have to get
right that nasa and its partners have to
get right to sort of make all that
technical choreography work so how does
nasa plan to achieve this historic
mission and how could artemis 1 pave the
way for future space exploration beyond
the lunar surface
there are several key space vehicles
involved in nasa's effort to get humans
back on the moon so there's
sls that's the the kind of rocket system
that starts the journey and on top of
that is orion which separates from the
rocket and then begins its journey to
lunar orbit there will also be a
separate lunar lander designed to take
astronauts from lunar orbit down to the
moon's surface that lander designed by
spacex is expected to be used on a
future artemis launch currently planned
for 2025.
the first mission artemis 1 will send
the crew capsule into orbit around the
moon for about six weeks allowing nasa
to test a series of critical systems
like life support before it puts people
on board
artemis ii will follow a similar path
but with astronauts on board and artemis
iii will carry people to the moon's
surface
nasa says this mission will be historic
for other reasons as well
it's opening the door
for the first woman and the first person
of color to set foot on the moon artemis
one will serve as a pathfinding mission
laying a foundation for future trips to
the moon it will also be the first test
flight of nasa's new space launch system
mega rocket and the orion crew capsule
another key objective will be testing
the spacecraft's heat shield it's meant
to protect the orion capsule from the
extreme temperatures it will encounter
entering earth's atmosphere at mach 32
which is around 24
500 miles per hour
the idea is to run all the hardware all
the software through its paces and show
that the rockets can fire the spacecraft
out of the gravitational pull of earth
and and the spacecraft can
separate and travel to the moon and get
back to this planet
safely nasa will also be monitoring
orion's navigation systems and its
resilience when traveling through high
radiation areas three mannequins on
board will be fitted with sensors to
determine how astronauts will fare on
the flight
another test will be recovering the
spacecraft after it splashes down in the
ocean
meanwhile the vehicles that nasa plans
to use for artemis 1 have face delays
the mission was originally scheduled to
take off in 2021. the contractors that
are are building the different elements
of the sls rocket system and
orion have run into technical challenges
and have had to
work those out they've faced supply
chain problems and some of these rockets
nasa has not attempted to have built and
launch in quite a long time so part of
the challenge was like simply getting
back up to speed on creating again
really big
really powerful rockets
the first artemis rocket and the broader
artemis program are expected to be
costly last november nasa's inspector
general forecasted the agency would
spend 93 billion dollars over more than
a dozen years on artemis with key costs
for the first launch expected to be
around 4.1 billion
nasa leaders have said the agency is
pushing to reduce costs for artemis and
streamline operations
some of the contractors that are
building the vehicles have said part of
the cost question
is because we've been in this
development mode building these for the
first time and when we build future
rockets and spacecraft the cost should
come down because we're simply in
production mode and not in this
developmental stage of creating the
vehicles for the first time
there are more long-term ambitions for
nasa's artemis programs astronauts will
live and work in deep space and we'll
develop the science and technology to
send the first humans to mars
the space agency has plans to build
gateway a multi-purpose outpost orbiting
the moon
it is also discussed developing a base
camp on the lunar surface more broadly
nasa says its return to the moon efforts
will help prepare for future exploration
of mars artemis now
has a vision of sending astronauts back
to the moon and creating sort of a
sustained infrastructure you know
pursuing science pursuing exploration
and the idea is that nasa will build all
of that infrastructure know-how hardware
to sort of make that happen
and use that knowledge base to pursue
the next frontier which is
some sort of trip to mars as the artemis
one launched eight nears nasa is
wrapping up several key tests to ensure
all the rocket systems will be ready to
go that 2025 timeline for getting
people down to the the surface of the
moon and back is coming up relatively
quickly the pressure is on to sort of
get get to that deadline and we'll see
if they can make it happen